moving on
our main story tonight concerns
unemployment the thing that would
absolutely happen to me if at t
executives ever find out what i've been
saying about them but on the other hand
what are they going to do look it up
online how with their internet plan
and then what call someone using a t
i think i'm fine unemployment can be a
traumatic event for anyone
even puppets why isn't mommy at work
today yesterday
i lost my job and i'm not going to be
working
at least for a little while
is it because elmo emma has too many
toys
oh no no baby none of this is your fault
it's nobody's fault well well
hold on there are we absolutely sure
that it's not elmo's fault
i don't know how much that plane costs
but i do know that maintaining a
crayon-colored liminal apartment where
you live part-time with dorothy of pet
fish
might be a problem for your now one
income family so
it's not not your fault elmo but also
quick shout out to elmo's mom there
she's going through some but she
still managed to get her hair up in two
strand twists before she went to bed the
night before
she's taking care of herself and
protecting those edges drop the routine
may
post a shelfie on the gram what are your
holy grail products patent beauty shea
moisture well you're still rocking at
old school with a bottle of pink oil and
a jar of jam
i see you elmo's mom but even for the
non-puppet population
unemployment is an especially pertinent
topic right now it's been almost
exactly a year since the pandemic hit
and
tens of millions of people lost their
jobs many of whom
foster unemployment insurance or
unemployment
our current system was created in the
1930s and the basic idea was
like most insurance to gather funds
particularly in the good times
so that there'd be money available to
disperse in bad times and to pay for all
of this
states would tax employers the concept
was enthusiastically promoted at the
time
with educational films like this to show
how job insurance works
let's introduce steve a louisiana worker
who has just lost his job
now each week the letter carrier brings
steve a check for half the normal weekly
wage
he used to earn the maximum is 15 the
minimum is five dollars
or three fourths of his earnings job
insurance
this is the way the state of louisiana
is doing its part
in the nationwide crusade against
unemployment
fear and insecurity yes and a boy
steve that newsreel of course from the
makers of such classics as
amelia earhart the woman who will never
die and
how to fight the nazis even though given
this era's prevalent anti-semitism you
most likely agree with a lot of what
they're saying
but unemployment wasn't just created to
save our nation's steves from
fear and insecurity economists generally
agree
that unemployment insurance is actually
one of the most effective policies
for recovering from a recession which
does make sense because
when you give the unemployed money they
tend not to hoard it
offshore in the caymans they spend it on
they need
in fact analysis from past recession
shows that every dollar
spent on unemployment benefits boosted
economy-wide spending
by as much as two dollars so it's a
vital social safety net
and has massive macroeconomic benefits
but despite that
over the years our system has badly
broken down
something that became painfully clear
this time last year when it was
overwhelmed by new claims we featured
stories on this show of people
having to call 50 times a day just to
make an unemployment claim but that
was the tip of the iceberg kentucky
residents poured into the capital for
their first chance to get an
in-person meeting at a pop-up
unemployment office since the pandemic
began
brianna glass applied three months ago
and is still having trouble getting
payments
she stood in line yesterday just days
after giving birth
i mean i've called i've emailed i did
everything i possibly could and
still nothing holy
waiting in line for unemployment just
after giving birth
is already appalling but the very phrase
pop-up
unemployment office is truly alarming
much like
emergency crematorium or elephant
forceps it suggests things have gone
terribly wrong
and are about to get significantly worse
now
some of last year's chaos was because
state antiquated systems were simply
overwhelmed but
it is a mistake to think of this merely
as a technological problem
because the system underneath that
shitty technology
has been broken for years now and
sometimes deliberately
a quick way to measure the health of a
state system is through its recipiency
rates that is basically
the percentage of unemployed people that
actually receive benefits now
it will never be a hundred percent in
this country because
rightly or wrongly not everyone out of
work is eligible generally
only those who are laid off are and that
is just over half of the unemployed the
rest
like those fresh out of school or who
quit voluntarily or who were fired are
generally
not covered that is why experts say that
under our current system
a good rule of thumb is that a state's
recipiency rate should be around
50 the problem is nationally even before
this pandemic
we were at just 28 and in some states
like north carolina and florida it was
around
10 percent just think about what that
means
out of every 10 unemployed people in
those states
only one is actually receiving benefits
if you boarded an airplane and learned
that only one in 10 seats had an oxygen
mask you would wonder
who designed this system why did they
make it this way
and how do i get the out of here
right now
so given that tonight let's look at our
current unemployment system and the
first thing to know is
it is not one system from the very start
states were given
huge latitude in running their
unemployment programs meaning that we
essentially have 53
completely different systems one for
each state plus
dc puerto rico and the virgin islands
and not only is that very inefficient
it means the level of benefits vary
wildly
massachusetts pays the most up to twelve
hundred thirty four dollars a week
florida's maximum 275 dollars a week
that is a hell of a difference and it's
something that people might want to
factor in
if they're considering moving somewhere
well the climate seems nicer and the
schools do seem decent but before i go
let me just google if i lose my job will
this state let me
starve and it's not just where you live
that determines your benefits it also
matters
what you do because many part-time
workers plus
independent contractors and gig workers
typically don't qualify for unemployment
which is absurd given that those jobs
make up a significant portion
of our modern workforce and incidentally
black workers are over-represented in
those type of jobs just as
they're over-represented in the states
with the least generous benefits which
might explain
why black workers are more likely to be
unemployed but
less likely to get unemployment benefits
and inequity
was baked into the system from the very
beginning in the 1930s agricultural and
domestic workers were initially
purposely excluded
meaning that 65 of black workers weren't
covered by the program
it seems in the us you can basically
point to anything ask
how is that racist and get a specific
historical answer
freeways demolished black communities
mickey mouse
based on minstrel shows this toddler
well his name is kendall so
it's only a matter of time the point is
for myriad reasons you may not be able
to get unemployment and even if you do
get it in many states
it might not be enough to live on that
is something
the federal government seem to basically
acknowledge was a problem last year when
it suddenly
temporarily expanded unemployment to
cover more workers and
boosted benefits by 600 across the board
so how did our system get this shitty
and whose fault is it is it elmo's the
answer
is not definitely no yet but the truth
is
a lot of the system shortcomings were
the result of deliberate choices
for one remember businesses fund
unemployment insurance
through taxes that go into state trust
funds and after the last financial
crisis drains those funds
states needed to restore them but rather
than do the sensible thing
raise taxes to get more money coming in
many opted instead just to cut benefits
and make them harder to get and as they
did this
some in the national media cheered them
on like sentient plantation wedding at
laura ingram
it's simple human nature that people are
a little less motivated
as long as there's a check coming in you
know what my mom used to say
god rest her soul when you're hungry
you'll figure out a way to eat right
hunger uh brings drive
hunger for opportunity hunger for uh
paycheck hunger for
uh actual food hunger for a lifestyle
a way of life boy you find it when
there's no
helping hand wow when you're hungry
you'll figure out a way to eat well
sometimes laura the problem is
sometimes not and then it's a tragedy
there's a reason that famines aren't
generally referred to as
a lack of can-do attitude and that kind
of rhetoric
has become pretty popular your most
racist uncle has undoubtedly said
something similar
probably to a waitress at red lobster
completely ruining mother's day
and that speaks to the kind of attitudes
toward the unemployed ranging from
simmering contempt to a callous
disregard that lie beneath
many states aggressive policy changes
over the past decade
starting in 2012 tennessee passed laws
making the process to apply
far more difficult one justification
being that somehow
loads of people ineligible for benefits
were still getting them which is
complete nonsense
but something that the lieutenant
governor back then ron ramsey
certainly believed if you were fired
from your job for just calls maybe even
for stealing from your employer or
chronic absenteeism you shouldn't be
able to draw unemployment you don't get
unemployment insurance if you're fired
for calls now
the law says they're not supposed to but
buddy let me assure you
nine times out of ten they get their
workers calling or whether they're
unemployment i can assure you that's
nine times out of ten i don't know about
that okay that was a ron ramsey
blanket statement there but there are
plenty of examples
that they get oh yeah don't worry that's
just a classic
ron ramsey blanket statement and you
know you're in good hands when a
government official
lies enough to warrant a
trademark now ramsay also argued for
drug testing the unemployed saying
i don't think we need to be supporting
that lifestyle with government money
which is not just an obvious attempt to
stigmatize
it also ignores that drugs are actually
helpful in some jobs like for instance
this one how do you think i talk this
fast about things this depressing
what do you even think this white void
is made out of i'm surrounded by weapons
grade cocaine
and it wasn't just tennessee lots of
states put in new owners requirements to
make sure that people getting benefits
deserved them for instance nebraska
started requiring
five work search activities per week
which could include
attending a resume writing class or
taking a civil service exam
but at least two of which had to be
applications for suitable work but
if there aren't two suitable work
opportunities for you to apply for that
week
you're out of luck and the problem
is each additional requirement
like that increases the chances that
someone's going to make a mistake
or fail to check a box and get denied
benefits that they need
and as they were doing this states were
also aggressively targeting fraud which
isn't in itself
a bad idea states do lose money to fraud
before the pandemic hit
it wasn't honestly a lot an average of
three percent but
that actually surged last year when
organized criminals
targeted unemployment programs and
california alone said it lost
11 billion dollars but the thing is you
have to be
very precise in how you go after fraud
because if a claim
is wrongly flagged it can be
significantly delayed and innocent
people
then get hurt that is something that
kentucky's governor recently found when
he shared
what he clearly thought was a pretty
flagrant example
we had somebody apply for unemployment
for tupac shakur here in kentucky
and that person probably thought they
were being funny they probably did
except for the fact that because of them
we've got to go through so many other
claims
okay he made a very confident public
example of that because he knew
no one could be called tupac shakur
right that is just not a name
that people have except of course
famously for this guy but we all know
he's living in the falkland islands
right now
no one else could have that name it's
absolutely impossible
i think you know what's coming next now
somebody an apology tonight
um you know last night i spent a little
bit of time
talking about fraudulent claims holding
us up and mentioned an individual that
had filed in the name of tupac shakur
i didn't know um and it's my fault
uh that we have a kentuckian who goes by
malik
whose name is tupac shakur i talked to
him on the phone today
i apologized yeah yeah i bet you did
and i will say that is just further
proof that nothing good can ever come
from a middle-aged white man
knowing anything about rap period we
just can't handle it
that's how you get macklemore and if
you're thinking hey what's so bad about
macklemore
you are very much part of the problem
here
and some mistakes happened on a much
bigger scale michigan
rolled out a new system in 2013 which
flagged tens of thousands of cases for
fraud unfortunately
a review four years later found it had a
70 percent
error rate meaning they falsely accused
more than 40
000 people of fraudulently claiming
benefits and
had been wrongfully recouping massive
amounts of money
from many of them and the problem with
the word recoup there is it sounds kind
of bloodless
until you realize that those people were
required to repay their benefits
at a 400 penalty which is
just brutal it's like a hospital
mistakenly thinking that a patient wrote
a bad check and deciding to
recoup their hip replacement hey
i didn't do anything wrong and i really
needed that
and if you want to see how all of this
poor technology
deep benefit cuts and absurd eligibility
requirements
can come together to break a vital
social program
look no further than florida america's
vestigial tale florida's previous
governor and slender man understudy rick
scott
took a hatchet to the states program
while in power when he was sworn in
employers that year paid an average of
319 dollars per
employee in unemployment taxes by the
time he left office
they were paying just 50 per employee
the lowest in the country and less than
one-fifth the national average
and to balance those cuts out as scott
proudly told a conference of young
republicans in 2019
he found ways to keep a lot of
floridians off unemployment
about 22 million people live in in
florida
how many people today get just uh throw
out a guess
how many people when i left office were
on unemployment benefits
10 million won anybody else
61 000.
wow that is some nervous applause
even in that room you can feel people
thinking wait
61 000 out of 22 million oh that feels
way too low
is what he did terrible are we all
terrible oh never mind we're clapping
now
okay i do feel better when we clap now
to achieve those numbers
scott employed all the tactics you've
seen florida started requiring that
people document contacts
with five employers per week reduced
total benefits by
slashing the number of weeks you could
receive them and throwing some extra
obstacles like requiring applicants to
complete a
45 question skills assessment testing
their reading math and research skills a
policy
so clearly meant to impede access the
department of labor's civil rights
division
determined it violated federal
non-discrimination law the state
also forced everyone to file online and
rolled out an expensive new claim system
which was immediately plagued with
glitches and despite all rick scott's
reassurances at the time
that they would be fixed they pretty
clearly weren't
because the system crashed so badly last
year they had to suddenly shift to paper
applications which
in the middle of a pandemic brought a
whole different set of problems
it was near bedlam at the john f kennedy
library in hialeah
a crowd in uncomfortably close quarters
shoved its way forward
with people desperate to get their hands
on one of these an application for
unemployment benefits i am so scared
what's going on
i'm scared for my life just for an
application
yeah i'm scared for your life too just
watching that
and it's a testament to both this
pandemic and florida's ridiculous system
that i feel the same white knuckle
terror watching people line up for
unemployment applications as i do
when watching a daredevil jump a
motorcycle over a row of buses although
to be honest
it's probably only a matter of time
before florida makes bus jumping
a requirement for applying for
unemployment there too and while you
could argue
that this was just incompetence you
could also argue it was completely
deliberate
many floridians actually suggested that
last year one of whom
was rick scott's successor i think the
goal was
for whoever designed it was let's put as
many kind of pointless roadblocks along
the way
so people just say oh the hell with it
i'm not going to do that but i think
definitely
in terms of how it was internally
constructed you know it was definitely
done in a way to
uh lead to the least number of of claims
being paid out
wow i gotta say it's kind of weird to
hear this
accurately critique this it'd be
like hearing
twitter really needs to take care of its
nazi problem
from mark zuckerberg sure in isolation
you're making a good point you just
happen to be a fundamentally flawed
messenger
because before you give desantis too
much credit there it is worth knowing
that a state investigation found that
auditors had flagged problems with
florida's system in 2015 2016
and 2019 and neither the scots nor
desantis administrations
fixed the problems and florida's deep
and deliberate neglect of its
unemployment system
caused people there real pain if the
unemployment claim finally went through
we would be able to pay our bills no
problem but
we tried to file for unemployment online
and
it was an absolute nightmare i
constantly have
a nauseous feeling in my stomach i try
to distract myself from it
but especially at night
i'm sorry i can't even put into words
i'm just
i don't want emmitt to see me upset i've
been fighting really hard to hold it
together
that's terrible and the infuriating
thing is how completely preventable it
is
we could help her it'd be better for her
it'd actually
be better for the broader economy and
yet we are actively choosing
not to do it which is a disgrace
so how can we fix this going
forward well first
there can no longer be any argument that
our current system is broken again
the government's actions last year
raising payments
and scrambling to make sure that the
system covered more workers is a
pretty public admission that it was
so now
we have to fix it in the very short term
states need funding to upgrade their
broken technology
they also need to remove a lot of the
stupid obstacles that prevent applicants
who need help
from getting it but in the long term we
need some big
changes here many experts agree if the
u.s got a do-over
it'd be much better to go with one
federal system
than 53 separate ones so we should
probably
do that among other things that would
stop states from being able to
slash their programs in the name of
being pro-business and engaging in a
race to the bottom on taxes but
if we are not going to federalize and at
the moment it seems like we're not
congress should at the very least be
setting a
basic standard for unemployment benefits
that states
cannot drop below all of which is really
just a long way of saying
that we need to take all of the energy
that we have been pouring in
to making sure that people who don't
deserve payments don't get them
and put at least as much energy into
making sure that people who really need
them
do and to not make big changes
after the flaws of this system have been
so brutally exposed
over the last year would be unforgivable
because if we don't fix it
we have absolutely nobody to blame but
ourselves
and possibly elmo i'm not sure exactly
how but the whole thing does somehow
still seem like his fault